ברוכים הבאים חזרה למחשוב קוונטי בפרקטיקה. זה פרק 6. היום אנחנו הולכים להתמקד באחד מהיישומים האהובים עליי
של מחשבים קוונטיים, סימולציה של הטבע. בפרק הזה, אנחנו הולכים לדון בצעדים הנדרשים
לעשות את זה עבור כל סוג של בעיית דינמיקה קוונטית, שהיא הבעיה של מציאת איך התיאור של
מערכת קוונטית משתנה עם הזמן. נעשה את זה ברמה גבוהה קודם ואז נסתכל על דוגמה ספציפית ונעבור
עליה בפירוט. כלומר הניסוי של IBM מ-2023 שהדגים תועלת קוונטית. בשביל קצת מוטיבציה מהירה
בהתחלה, אחד הסיפורים הכי מפורסמים שאנחנו בתחום המחשוב הקוונטי מספרים שוב ושוב,
הסיפור של Richard Feynman שנתן הרצאה ב-Caltech ב-1959 ובעצם
סיפק מוטיבציה לכל התחום לעשורים קדימה. ההרצאה נקראה יש המון מקום בתחתית
כותרת מצחיקה, אבל הרעיון הבסיסי היה שהוא טען שיש עדיין כל כך הרבה פיזיקה עשירה לגלות
ברמה המיקרוסקופית.
עכשיו, ההרצאה הספציפית הזו לא קיבלה הרבה תשומת לב עד שנות ה-80 כשהטכנולוגיה התפתחה לא מעט. ו-Feynman
גם הבהיר ושיפר את המסר שלו עם הזמן. הוא חזר ל-Caltech בשנות ה-80 והציג מאמר נוסף שנקרא
סימולציה של הטבע עם מחשבים שם הוא אמר ספציפית שהוא רוצה לדבר על האפשרות שתהיה
סימולציה מדויקת שבה המחשב יעשה בדיוק את מה שהטבע עושה.
בעצם להיות מסוגלים להיפטר מקירובים גסים של מה שקורה בקנה מידה אטומי ולהחליף אותם עם
מחשבים שמבינים ורותמים פיזיקה קוונטית לא רק לסמלץ את מה שהטבע עושה, אלא לחקות אותו.
עכשיו, זכרו את הגרפיקה של ציר הזמן שהראיתי בפרק קודם. בקצה אחד, היו לנו בעיות שהיה קל
לפתור ולא ידרשו שום סוג של האצה שקוונטום יכול להציע. אבל בקצה השני, יש לנו בעיות שהן
מאוד קשות ודורשות מכונות קוונטיות עמידות לתקלות שעדיין אין לנו.
למזלנו, אנחנו מאמינים שיש לא מעט בעיות סימולציה שנמצאות כאן באמצע, שזה האזור
שאנחנו יכולים לעבוד בו כרגע. ויש הרבה סיבות להתלהב ולהיות מסוקרנים מהסיכוי הזה כי
סימולציה של הטבע היא הבסיס להרבה תחומי יישום מרגשים. רק כדי לנקוב בכמה. אם יכולנו לסמלץ טוב יותר
את הטבע, יכולנו להאיץ את גילוי חומרים חדשים, ליצור תרופות ורפואה טובים יותר, או
אפילו לחקור פיזיקה חדשה שעומדת בבסיס פיזיקת חלקיקים או קוסמולוגיה. אבל לפני שאתם או אני או מישהו יכול לנסות
ליישם מחשוב קוונטי לתחומים המרגשים האלה, לעת עתה, תצטרכו להבין את הצעדים הבסיסיים בתהליך
עבודה טיפוסי מבוסס סימולציה.
קודם כל, תרצו לזהות מערכת קוונטית שמעניינת אתכם. זה ייתן לכם מידע על ההמילטוניאן ששולט בהתפתחות
שלה בזמן ותיאור משמעותי של המאפיינים ההתחלתיים שלה או המצב שלה.
אחר כך תצטרכו למצוא שיטה מתאימה ליישום התפתחות הזמן של המצב הזה. עם המרכיבים האלה
מסודרים, הצעדים הבאים כוללים ביצוע הניסוי בפועל.
בדרך כלל אלה כוללים אופטימיזציה של יישום ה-circuit של אלגוריתם התפתחות הזמן, הרצת
ה-circuit או ה-circuits על חומרה קוונטית ועיבוד מאוחר של התוצאות. אז אנחנו
יכולים לפרט את הצעדים הבסיסיים בניסוי סימולציה כך.
זיהוי המילטוניאן של המערכת, קידוד המילטוניאן, הכנת מצב, התפתחות מצב,
אופטימיזציה של circuit, הרצת circuit, ועיבוד מאוחר.
אבל אלה צעדים די מפורטים. זכרו שארבעת השלבים של מסגרת Qiskit patterns, שעוזרת
לנו להבין איך ליישם שגרה ב-Qiskit הם מיפוי, אופטימיזציה של circuit, הרצת circuit, ו-
עיבוד מאוחר. אז ארבעת הצעדים הראשונים האלה כלולים למעשה תחת המטריה של מיפוי וזו
הסיבה שהקדשנו פרק שלם לשלב הראשון הזה ואם פספסתם אותו בבקשה חזרו וצפו בפרק הקודם.
עכשיו בואו קודם נעבור על מה הצעדים האלה בכלל אומרים לפני שנצלול לכתיבת קוד. אז הדבר הבסיסי הראשון שצריך
לעשות כדי לבצע ניסוי סימולציה הוא לזהות את ההמילטוניאן שמתאר את המערכת. לפעמים, ובעצם
לעתים קרובות, אלה ידועים, פעמים אחרות צריך להרכיב אותו מהבנת תרומות האנרגיה
של תת-קבוצות קטנות של המערכת המלאה כמו כאן שבו hi הוא ההמילטוניאן הפועל על אחת מ-n תת-המערכות של h.
נצטרך גם לציין אם המערכת מורכבת מפרמיונים או בוזונים אם אנחנו עוסקים בחלקיקים אלמנטריים. הלאה,
צריך לקודד את ההמילטוניאן ולתרגם אותו למונחים שמחשבים קוונטיים יכולים להבין. הרבה פעמים,
ההמילטוניאנים האלה יהיו מורכבים מחלקיקים אלמנטריים או מערכות ספין. אם היינו מסמלצים פרמיונים או בוזונים,
נצטרך לבחור טרנספורמציית קידוד כמו Jordan-Wigner או Bravyi-Kitaev. הטרנספורמציות האלה
יגידו לנו איך לתרגם את ההגדרה של ההמילטוניאן הכתובה במונחים של הרכיבים המקוריים, הפרמיונים או
הבוזונים לאופרטורי פאולי שמומרים בקלות ל-gates במחשב קוונטי. לדוגמה, טרנספורמציית Jordan-Wigner
המוגדרת כאן נותנת מיפוי מאופרטורים פרמיוניים לאופרטורי פאולי. אם אנחנו כבר עוסקים
במערכות ספין חצי שהן מאוד נפוצות אז אנחנו בסדר מלבד אולי מקדמי נרמול
ולא צריך להשתמש בסכמת קידוד. אחרי שקידדנו את ההמילטוניאן הרצוי לתוך סט ה-gates של
המחשב הקוונטי, הצעד הקריטי הבא הוא לקבוע את המצב הקוונטי ההתחלתי המתאים ממנו נתחיל את
הסימולציה. המצב הזה צריך באופן אידיאלי לשקף משמעות פיזית כלשהי או תצורה של
המערכת הנחקרת. לדוגמה, אם אנחנו מעוניינים לחקור את אנרגיית מצב היסוד של מולקולה, אנחנו עשויים
להתחיל עם קירוב Hartree-Fock או מצב אחר שקל להכין שיש לו חפיפה משמעותית עם מצב
היסוד האמיתי. הבחירה של מצב התחלתי משפיעה לא רק על ההתכנסות של אלגוריתמים וריאציוניים
כמו VQE הפותר הקוונטי הוריאציוני אלא גם על הדיוק והיעילות של
התפתחות זמן או דגימה בהערכת פאזה קוונטית. בעצם, המצב ההתחלתי משמש כ-
נקודת השיגור של החישוב, מכין את הבמה לחילוץ נצפים שימושיים על המערכת הקוונטית
שאנחנו ממדלים. הכנה של מצב שרירותי של n qubit כאשר ci הם מצבי הבסיס החישובי ו-ai הוא
המקדם המתאים של כל מצב ותנאי הנרמול 2 בחזקת n מינוס אחד ניתנת לגישה באופן כללי על ידי
אתחול המצב עם האופרטור o. מצב ההתחלה יהיה מצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי של כולם אפס שנכתב לעתים קרובות
ככה לפשטות. באופן כללי זה דורש מספר אקספוננציאלי של gates מסוג C-NOT. הרבה פעמים אנחנו
מעוניינים במצב התחלתי ספציפי למערכת וההכנה שלו יכולה להיות מיושמת עם כמות סבירה
של משאבים. מצבי מכפלה לדוגמה שבהם ה-qubits לא שזורים זה עם זה דורשים רק פעולות
של qubit יחיד. עכשיו עדיין לא הייתה לנו הזדמנות לדבר על טרוטריזציה
אם כי חלקכם בטח כבר מכירים את זה. בעצם, טרוטריזציה היא שיטה לחישוב העלאה למעריך של מטריצה ש-
משתמשת בקירובים כדי לטפל בטבע האקספוננציאלי של אופרטורים שלא מתחלפים. כשני אופרטורים כמו HA
ו-HB לא מתחלפים, אז אנחנו צריכים להשתמש בטריק חכם ולהפעיל לסירוגין את האקספוננציאלים המתאימים של
e בחזקת מינוס i HA ו-e בחזקת מינוס i HB למספר n של
פעמים. אופרטורי ההתפתחות המתחלפים מופעלים. אני לא אעבור על ההוכחה כאן, אבל אשתף קישור
להוכחה פשוטה ונחמדה של הטענה הזו בתיאור. אבל המסר העיקרי הוא זה. התפתחות זמן היא חלק
חשוב מהמיפוי גם. טרוטריזציה מפרקת אינטראקציה רציפה לצעדים בדידים שניתנים
ליישום על מחשב קוונטי. אחרי יצירת ה-circuit המטרוטר, סוף סוף סיימנו את
שלב המיפוי. עכשיו אפשר לעבור לאופטימיזציה של ה-circuit.
כדי לעשות את זה, הנה מה שצריך להשיג. צריך פריסת qubit שממפה את ה-qubits הווירטואליים של
ה-circuit שלכם ל-qubits פיזיים על החומרה. זה נדרש כי לחומרה יכולות להיות טופולוגיות מסוימות
שמגבילות את האינטראקציה הישירה של qubits פיזיים. בעוד שהיישום של
circuit קוונטי לעתים קרובות מניח את היכולת של כל qubit לתקשר עם כל qubit אחר. אז צריך להוסיף
gates של swap לפי הצורך כדי לנתב אינטראקציות בין qubits שלא מחוברים. צריך לתרגם את
ה-gates ב-circuit שלנו להוראות של ארכיטקטורת סט ההוראות או ISA
שניתנות להרצה ישירה על החומרה. אחר כך צריך לבצע אופטימיזציות של circuit כדי למזער את
עומק ה-circuit ומספר ה-gates. הצעד הזה יכול להתבצע גם על ה-circuit הווירטואלי. ה-circuit שבו ה-qubits
עדיין לא מופו לטופולוגיית מכשיר. אבל זכרו שהרבה מזה נעשה אוטומטית בשבילכם ב-
Qiskit. נראה בדיוק איך בחלק הבא של ההרצאה הזו. אחרי שלב האופטימיזציה, אנחנו מוכנים להריץ
את ה-circuit באמצעות פרימיטיב. עבור רוב ניסויי הסימולציה, אתם מעוניינים להבין את השינוי
של מאפיינים מסוימים של המערכת עם הזמן. אז סביר שתשתמשו בפרימיטיב האסטימייטור כי זה
יאפשר לכם למדוד את ערכי התוחלת של נצפים המתאימים למאפיינים ספציפיים. אחר כך
נגדיר את האפשרויות הטובות ביותר לאסטימייטור שיכולות להוסיף טכניקות דיכוי שגיאות והפחתת שגיאות. לבסוף, נריץ את
הניסוי. הצעד האחרון הוא עיבוד מאוחר של כל הנתונים. זה מחלץ את ערכי התוחלת הנמדדים או אם
אתם משתמשים בסמפלר, את התפלגות ההסתברות של הדגימה בבסיס החישובי. אם כל מה שצריך
הם ערכי התוחלת של הנצפים שמעניינים אותנו, אפשר לקבל אותם ישירות מפרימיטיב האסטימייטור
גם בערכים הגולמיים שלהם וגם בערכים עם הפחתת שגיאות. הרבה פעמים משתמשים בערכי התוחלת הנמדדים
לחישובים אחרים של גדלים אחרים שמעניינים אותנו שלא דורשים חישוב קוונטי ואפשר
לחשב אותם על מחשב קלאסי.
עכשיו אנחנו הולכים לעבור על דוגמה אמיתית ממאמר מאוד משפיע ש-IBM פרסמה לפני כמה שנים שנקרא
הוכחה לתועלת של מחשוב קוונטי לפני סבילות לתקלות. עכשיו המאמר הזה שאנחנו מכנים בחיבה
מאמר התועלת הפך למאמר מאוד משפיע בתחום המחשוב הקוונטי כמעט מיד עם הפרסום.
התזה הכללית של המאמר היא שמחשב קוונטי רועש הפיק תוצאות מדויקות או ערכי תוחלת
באמצעות 127 qubits ו-2,880 gates מחוץ ליכולות של חישוב
בכוח גס שהוא הסימולציה המדויקת של ה-circuits הקוונטיים שהורצו על החומרה. העבודה הזו הייתה
חשובה גם כי היא הראתה שמחשב קוונטי יכול לשמש לאימות או השוואת תוצאות עם שיטות
קלאסיות קירוביות אחרות לסימולציות קוונטיות כמו אלגוריתמים של רשתות טנזור שבהם הפתרון
לא היה ידוע מראש. מה שגם די מגניב הוא שעכשיו אחרים שמשתמשים במערכות IBM הקוונטיות על
הענן ו-Qiskit יכולים לשכפל ולאמת את התוצאות האלה בעצמם.
אני הולך להראות לכם איך לעשות בדיוק את זה. אז בדוגמה הזו, ניכנס קצת יותר לפרטים של
הצעדים המעורבים במיפוי הבעיה הזו לקלטים שמכשיר קוונטי יכול להבין. במקרה הזה, אנחנו נסמלץ
את הדינמיקה של המגנטיזציה הכוללת של מערכת של דיפולים מגנטיים על רשת
בנוכחות שדה מגנטי חיצוני. המערכת יכולה להיות מתוארת על ידי מודל אייזינג עם שדה מגנטי רוחבי.
אנחנו ממדלים את זה עם circuit קוונטי פרמטרי שבו הפרמטרים מתאימים לערך המכוונן של
אינטראקציית הספין-ספין או Z והעוצמה של השדה המגנטי X. עכשיו,
הסדרה הזו נקראת מחשוב קוונטי בפרקטיקה. אז, אנחנו גם הולכים לדון בנהלים בניסוי הזה
שאנחנו הולכים ליישם כדי לעשות את התוצאות הכי טובות שאפשר. אז הלאה נדון באיך להסיר
qubits גרועים או qubits עם נאמנות gate נמוכה או זמני דה-קוהרנטיות שיכולים להשפיע באופן דרמטי על
תוצאות הניסוי. qubits גרועים אלה יכולים להיווצר בגלל כיול קודם לקוי
או מערכות דו-רמתיות שמתקשרות עם ה-qubit. הסרת כמה qubits מהטופולוגיה המקורית של החומרה מתאימה
לשקילה של מערכת על רשת שמתוארת על ידי הטופולוגיה שנוצרת. אנחנו גם הולכים לדון ביצירת
ה-circuit הקוונטי הפרמטרי שמיישם את התפתחות הזמן של המערכת באמצעות טרוטריזציה.
למטרה הזו, יהיה חשוב לזהות שכבות שזירה שהן חלק קריטי בטכניקת הפחתת השגיאות
העיקרית שנשתמש בה בהמשך. אז בנקודה הזו אני רוצה לוודא שאתם הקהל יודעים
שאתם יכולים לעקוב אחרי כל מה שאני עומד לדון בו במדריך המקושר למטה ובפלטפורמת הלמידה של IBM
הקוונטית. במדריך הזה, מה שאולי תשימו לב אליו הוא שיצרנו סדרה של פונקציות עזר
בתחילת המחברת שאנחנו יכולים לקרוא להן אחר כך כדי להקל על החיים שלנו. אני רוצה להזכיר את אלה
עכשיו, לא כי זה חלק מהתהליך הרשמי, אלא כי זה מה שנסיינים עושים בדרך כלל
בחיים האמיתיים כדי לעזור להם להריץ סוגים כאלה של ניסויים. וזה גם מראה לנו איך אנחנו הולכים לפרק את
הבעיה שלנו עוד יותר. הפונקציות שאנחנו מגדירים במחברת הן כדלקמן. הסרת צימודי qubit.
הגדרת צימודי qubit. בניית צימודי שכבות. בניית שכבות שזירה. ולבסוף, הגדרת
circuit מטרוטר. הלאה, בואו נדבר על צימודי שכבות, שעוזרים להגדיר איך qubits
מתקשרים עם השכנים שלהם במהלך הסימולציה. המכשירים הקוונטיים שלנו משתמשים במשהו שנקרא פריסה
הקסגונלית כבדה. תבנית מיוחדת לחיבור qubits. בפריסה הזו, אנחנו יכולים לקבץ את החיבורים שנקראים צלעות לשלושה
סטים נפרדים שבהם אף שני חיבורים באותו סט לא חולקים qubit. זה
חשוב כי במחשב קוונטי אמיתי, אי אפשר להריץ gates של שני qubits באותו זמן אם הם מערבים את
אותו qubit. כל qubit יכול להיות מעורב רק ב-gate אחד בכל פעם. על ידי
חלוקת כל החיבורים לשלוש שכבות, אנחנו יכולים להפעיל gates של שני qubits על פני כל המכשיר בשלושה
סבבים, ולוודא ששום qubit לא משמש ביותר מ-gate אחד לכל שכבה. ה-gates
האלה מיישמים את אינטראקציית ה-ZZ ממודל Ising, והם חוזרים בכל צעד של הסימולציה שנקרא
צעד טרוטר. טווירלינג משנה את הרעש במכשיר כך שאפילו מודל רעש פשוט
צפוי להיות מדויק. זה גם מאפשר ללמוד בצורה מדויקת את מודל הרעש ולהשתמש במידע שהושג
בטכניקות הפחתת שגיאות.
הלאה, צריך להסיר את ה-qubits הגרועים שלנו מהרשימה האפשרית של qubits פיזיים שאנחנו יכולים להשתמש בהם
לניסוי. כמו שאמרתי, qubit יכול להפוך לגרוע ממגוון סיבות שונות. לפעמים זה פשוט
כיול לקוי, טעות פשוטה שאפשר לפתור רק על ידי כיול מחדש.
לפעמים זה קצת יותר מסובך וקשור למשהו שאנחנו קוראים לו TLS, שהוא פגם ממשקי דו-רמתי
שמוביל לתנודות בפרמטרי ה-qubit ולרלקסציה. את זה אפשר
לפתור על ידי חימום קל של כל המערכת ואז קירור חזרה. אבל זה לוקח זמן ולא ניתן
לעשות את זה דרך הענן. אז לעת עתה, הדבר הכי קל לעשות הוא פשוט להוציא אותם מהרשימה של qubits
פיזיים אפשריים שנשתמש בהם. אפשר לזהות אילו qubits לא מתנהגים כצפוי בקלות מפלטפורמת IBM הקוונטית.
אפשר לשרטט את מאפייני ה-qubit שם בפלטפורמה או להוריד אותם כ-CSV. אז ליצור רשימה של כל
ה-qubits שרוצים להוציא ופשוט להסיר אותם מרשימת כל ה-qubits הפיזיים במכשיר.
בסדר. עכשיו בואו נמשיך עם שלב המיפוי שלנו ונייצר את ה-circuit המטרוטר. עכשיו כמו שהראינו
קודם טרוטריזציה מפרקת את התפתחות הזמן לסדרה של צעדים ואנחנו צריכים להחליט כמה צעדים.
נבחר שישה כאן. אבל באופן כללי האסטרטגיה היא לאזן בין משהו שנקרא שגיאת טרוטר שהיא
שגיאת קירוב אלגוריתמית לבין השגיאה הנובעת מדה-קוהרנטיות. יותר צעדי טרוטר מקטינים את שגיאת
הקירוב אבל דורשים circuits קוונטיים עמוקים יותר שחווים יותר רעש דה-קוהרנטיות. נגדיר את
ה-circuit במונחים של פרמטר תטא שהוא העוצמה של השדה המגנטי החיצוני, צימודי שכבות ו-
מספר הצעדים וה-qubits וכמובן ה-backend של המכשיר. בגלל
התלות של המגנטיזציה של המערכת בעוצמת השדה המגנטי החיצוני, מעניין
להריץ את הסימולציה בערכים שונים של עוצמת השדה המגנטי שמתורגמים לזוויות שונות של RX
עבור הסיבוב של RX ב-circuit. עכשיו אחרי שיצרנו את ה-circuit שלנו, נעבור לאופטימיזציה שלו.
הצעד הראשון כאן הוא להגדיר מנהל מעברים. זכרו שבהקשר של Qiskit SDK, transpilation מתייחסת ל-
תהליך של הפיכת circuit קלט לצורה שמתאימה להרצה על מכשיר קוונטי.
transpilation מתרחשת בדרך כלל ברצף של צעדים שנקראים מעברי transpiler. מנהל מעברים הוא אובייקט
שמאחסן רשימה של מעברי transpiler ויכול להריץ אותם על circuit. יוצרים מנהל מעברים על ידי אתחול אובייקט
מנהל מעברים עם רשימה של מעברי transpiler. בסופו של דבר, מנהל המעברים
שלנו ייצור circuit מסוג ISA, circuit שחייב להיות כתוב במונחים של ארכיטקטורת סט ההוראות של ה-backend,
שמתאר את ה-circuit וה-gates שמקוריים ל-backend אבל חסר להם מידע התזמון הנדרש להרצת
ה-circuit. עכשיו אנחנו מוכנים להריץ את ה-circuit שלנו שזה שלב שלוש של Qiskit patterns. עכשיו כמו שנאמר קודם
בהחלט נשתמש באסטימייטור כאן כפרימיטיב הנבחר שלנו לניסוי הזה כי אנחנו רוצים למדוד את
המגנטיזציה הכוללת של המערכת והערכת ערך התוחלת של הנצפים היא מה שהאסטימייטור תוכנן
בשבילו. בשלב הזה גם יהיה קריטי לציין את האפשרויות שלנו להפחתת שגיאות. נשתמש באקסטרפולציית אפס רעש
כדי לקבל את התוצאות הכי טובות שאפשר. בפרט במדריך, תראו שאנחנו מציינים שניים או יותר
ערכי גורם רעש שבהם להעריך את המודלים המאקסטרפולים ומציינים
הגברת שגיאות הסתברותית כאפשרות ההגברה שלנו. עכשיו, הגברת
שגיאות הסתברותית או PEA הייתה באמת שיטת הפחתת השגיאות המועדפת כאן כי היא מתרחבת הרבה
יותר טוב מהאפשרויות האחרות. וזה מה שחשוב כשעובדים ברמה של 100 פלוס qubits.
אחרון חביב, מריצים את הניסוי וזה ייקח קצת זמן להסתיים, אבל לעת עתה, בואו נתייחס לנתונים
שנשמרו מהמדריך. נבחן את המטא-דאטה ונשים לב במיוחד ל-gates השכבתיים ו-
לשכבות המופחתות כי אנחנו עומדים להשתמש בהם כדי להסיר המון שגיאות מהנתונים הגולמיים שלנו. אנחנו כמעט מוכנים
לשרטט את התוצאות הסופיות שלנו. אבל לפני כן, בואו נוסיף במהירות אינטרלוד כאן על מה בדיוק הכוונה באקסטרפולציית
אפס רעש או ZNE. כיסינו את זה בקצרה בפרקים קודמים, אבל לסיכום, אקסטרפולציית אפס רעש
היא טכניקת הפחתת שגיאות שמסירה את ההשפעות של רעש לא ידוע במהלך הרצת circuit שניתן
לשנות את קנה המידה שלו בצורה ידועה. היא מניחה שערכי תוחלת משתנים עם הרעש לפי פונקציה ידועה שמוצגת כאן שבה
פרמטרי הלמבדא מציינים את עוצמת הרעש וניתנים להגברה. אפשר ליישם ZNE עם הצעדים הבאים.
קודם, מגבירים את רעש ה-circuit לכמה גורמי רעש. למבדא 1, למבדא 2,
למבדא 3, וכן הלאה. מריצים כל circuit מוגבר רעש כדי למדוד את
ערך התוחלת a של למבדא 1, a של למבדא 2, וכן הלאה. ואז מאקסטרפולים חזרה לגבול אפס הרעש,
ערך התוחלת a של אפס.
האתגר העיקרי ביישום מוצלח של ZNE הוא שיהיה מודל מדויק לרעש בערך התוחלת
ולהגביר את הרעש בצורה ידועה.
יש שלוש דרכים נפוצות ליישום הגברת שגיאות ל-ZNE: שינוי קנה מידה של משך הפולס דרך כיול,
חזרה על gates במחזורי זהות, והוספת רעש דרך דגימת ערוצי פאולי.
לאחרונה אנחנו קוראים PEA. הגברת שגיאות הסתברותית היא הבחירה הטובה ביותר כאן כי מתיחת פולסים היא מאוד
יקרה חישובית. קיפול gates חסר ערבויות תיאורטיות בשימור הטיית הרעש. אבל PEA ניתנת ל-
יישום על כל circuit שיכול לרוץ עם גורמי רעש מקוריים אבל דורשת לימוד מודל הרעש. PEA מניחה
את אותו מודל רעש מבוסס שכבות כמו ביטול שגיאות הסתברותי.
עם זאת, היא נמנעת מתקורת הדגימה שגדלה אקספוננציאלית עם רעש ה-circuit. כדי ללמוד את מודל הרעש,
צריך קודם לזהות את השכבות הייחודיות של פעולות שני qubits ב-circuit.
לכל שכבה, מבצעים טווירל פאולי ל-gates של שני qubits כדי לוודא שהרעש מתואר היטב על ידי מודל רעש דעיכה.
חוזרים על זוגות זהות של שכבות בעומקים משתנים ולבסוף מתאימים נאמנות או שגיאה לכל ערוץ רעש. ו-
כמובן, בעוד שאני ממליץ להבין את השיטה הזו במידה מסוימת, לעשות את זה ביד ב-Qiskit זה
הרבה יותר פשוט כמו שמוצג במדריך. עכשיו, סוף סוף, בואו נסתכל על הנתונים המשורטטים. הקו
האפור המנוקד מראה את התוצאות המדויקות שהושגו עם שיטות קלאסיות קירוביות ששגיאת הקירוב שלהן
התכנסה לסף נמוך. כמו שאתם יכולים לראות, הנתונים הגולמיים לגורמי הרעש השונים שבחרנו ב-
התחלה נמצאים במרחק ניכר מהקו המנוקד הזה. הקו הכחול הרציף מראה את הנתונים תוך התחשבות בעיבוד
ה-ZNE שלנו. ואפשר לראות מיד שזה הרבה יותר קרוב לתוצאות המדויקות.
לסיכום, הערכים הרועשים מראים סטייה גבוהה מהערכים המדויקים.
הערכים המופחתים קרובים לערכים המדויקים, מה שמדגים את התועלת של טכניקת ההפחתה מבוססת PEA.
וזה בעצם מסכם את הפרק הזה. לסכם במהירות את מה שלמדנו, סימולציה קוונטית היא אחד
מתחומי היישום המבטיחים ביותר בטווח הקצר עד הבינוני.
יש לה יישומים נרחבים מתרופות ועד פיזיקה של אנרגיות גבוהות,
מדעי החומרים ועוד. מאמר התועלת של IBM שפורסם ב-2023 הצביע
על הדרך לקראת היכולת להשתמש במחשבים קוונטיים לגילוי מדעי. ואנחנו עברנו על
המדריך המשויך שהולך יחד עם המאמר הזה לעומק. הצעדים לעבודה על בעיית סימולציה מההתחלה
ועד הסוף הם יחסית פשוטים, במיוחד ברגע שנכנסים לעניינים. והתקווה שלי היא שאתם
תוכלו מעכשיו להשתמש בסרטון הזה ובמדריך כמדריך לעוד בעיות סימולציה בעתיד.
תודה שצפיתם ונתראה בפעם הבאה במחשוב קוונטי בפרקטיקה.